So our design process for many projects is very customer led.
So what we've created is a development kit where you can buy
our actuator modules on assemblies that you can kind
of snap together with as many actuators as you need,
as many actuators sizes as you need,
in whatever orientation that you want at your facility with your product.
And your engineering team can start to explore what is the exact configuration
of the system that best satisfies what you
need to do because ultimately you understand your product best.
You know how your product works.
You know how it's presented to the robot.
You know what the packaging looks like.
And so when they're done doing
their development process they can then contact us and say,
you know, this is the design that we came up with.
And we'll take that design and we'll convert it into
a version that is very very robust for an industrial environment.
We also do our own internal gripper development
for projects and problems that we're incredibly excited about.
And often the way that development process works is you go to the store,
so you go to a supermarket or you go to
a toy store or you go to an e-commerce fulfillment site,
start buying piles of objects.
So you take the things that you just bought,
you start building a gazillion different grippers trying to
see what are the grasp parameters that drive quality of the grasp.
You also start playing around with the control systems that we build.
You know the pneumatic control system to figure out what sort of
pneumatic profiles deliver the best quality in an application and you kind of build up,
build up, build up from there until you have the finalized concept.
So my day at soft robotics typically focuses on the actuators themselves.
You know since this is a brand new field of science and
engineering there's a lot of things that need to be worked out.
So even building an actuator, a sophisticated actuator,
requires inventing the prototyping methods that then create
the thing that you want to even test in the first place. So that's a piece of it.
Understanding how to simulate elastomers for example
is an ever increasingly sophisticated science.
And new software is coming out all the time
that's driving the quality of the simulations.
But that's the thing.
And once you've done the prototyping and the simulation and you're building, you know,
a couple of parts that generate the sort of
physical behaviors you're trying to create for a customer,
you then need to do the process of starting to scale up to manufacturing.
Starting to build out what would be
the bulk manufacturing processes that
can create the thing that you just prototyped up in lab,
and making sure that they meet all the sorts of
functional and functional performance tests that you want it to have hit.
So, you know, does it last long enough?
Is it easily abraded?
Is it easy to make?
Because, ultimately, unlike the stuff that people typically build in lab,
you need to pump out thousands, ten thousands,
hundred thousands, you know,
millions of these actuators.
So you need to be able to drive it through
that whole process and so that's what I focus heavily on.
But in order to build soft robotic systems that are
sophisticated and truly satisfy a customer's needs where,
in our case, that typically means being able to manipulate complex objects
very quickly in a way that is extremely reproducible.
So the standards in industrial automation is essentially that you get it right all day,
every day, all year.
Because otherwise you shut down a factory line which is an incredible cost.
So being able to go from hobbyist work
to systems that deliver that level of precision and
accuracy requires not just soft robotic actuators but a whole marriage of systems.
You know, the pneumatics,
the pneumatic control system,
the AI software, you name it.
If it's in a conventional robot, it's in what we do,
plus having to also understand all the different new aspects of soft actuators.
Simulations are never perfect.
Anyone who's run the simulation knows that.
And when you run experiments,
even if the experiment works,
you never always completely glean everything that was relevant about what just happened.
You can actually miss a lot of insights if you don't have simulation.
So, doing fast iteration through simulation,
followed by fast iteration through experiment,
and marching forward like that's always best,
you know, personally in all the work that I do.
Now, as far as simulating the industrial environments,
it's very common in industry to have
battery workflow simulation software where you have your conveyor,
or you have your robot,
you have whatever is the process you're trying to mock up.
So that you can understand all the things that are creating choke points
for rates on in order to create a very very streamlined factory.
And, you know, we build gripping solutions but
factories are a whole myriad of different kinds of technologies.
So that's the simulation that they do.
As far as the simulation that we do, for the most part,
the simulation focus heavily on the actuators themselves.
So there are a lot of things that you can learn
computationally about how different patternings of plastics and
elastomers or multiple different kinds of elastomers where you have
variable stiffness all over the body and other mechanical properties materials.
It's a lot easier often or a lot more efficient to
kind of get a first pass at what that actuator is going to do and you know,
in FAA style simulation space.
And then iterate from there with physical versions of the actuator moving, you know,
in increasing sophistication and how you build
the actuator and how you run the simulation model.
And so that creates deep insights that we work really hard to build here.
And it creates a very very rapid development process.